the world chess Hall of Fame features an
enormous number of exhibits over a year
you'll be just amazed at how many
rotations that go through they have this
wonderful exhibit this photograph and
photography exit yes Harry Benson Queens
is up right now marvelous and one of the
women who make it all possible Emily
she's with yes Emily our head of the
world chess all of Fame and I work with
Emily a lot myself being on the board
okay she's a real fountain of knowledge
she's with parties right and it's one of
those things that you guys see us in
front of the camera doing our thing
talking about great games but so much
goes on behind the scenes here at the
Chess Club and across the street at the
world chess all of Fame and so many
people responsible for those great
exhibits and Emily already whose
assistant associate curator at the Hall
of Fame is with us to share some of that
knowledge
first of all Emily welcome to the show
now give us a little insight because
people you know we do some exhibitions
like you would expect but explore the
history of chess but we also have a
pretty broad mission so we explore chess
and art and chess in popular culture so
right now we have three really fantastic
exhibitions and on the first floor
there's a st. Louis artist named Peter
Mannion and he kind of takes a different
approach to chess so you might think of
chess pieces when you think of chess art
but he created these really beautiful
abstract pieces made of plaster on felt
and so it's kind of not even just
sculptural pieces it's an immersive
environment and he's actually a donor to
our collection too he donated a chess
computer that moves the pieces on its
own as you know you play against the
computer and on our second floor we have
Harry Benson kings and queens and so
that's a photographer who's really
famous not only for photographing the
1972 World Chess Championship but
basically any amazing celebrity you can
think of from the 20 and 21st centuries
so we have everyone from Michael Jackson
to Queen Latifah to Boris Spassky and
Bobby Fischer and then we have some
photography that's never been exhibited
before that was taken at the 2014 and
2018 Sinquefield cuts showing Fabiano
Caruana
then the third floor it's only on view
for a few more days but it's called the
sink field effect and it explores this
resurgence in American chess that's been
kind of centered here in st. Louis so we
do we try to do something that's a
little bit of everything you know for
you can bring in someone who doesn't
know a lot about chess or you can bring
in you know a grandmaster and they'll
enjoy it now all this great stuff I love
going over to the world chess Hall of
Fame as far as you're concerned what's
your job exactly cuz it feels like you
do a little bit of everything that's
exactly what I was going to say so it's
anything from like last year we worked
on that book together you know doing
this book about the Sinquefield Cup in
its first five years - we did this year
and last year we've contributed a chesty
mini golf hole to another institution
summer exhibition cycle we've worked on
shows for the airport and things like
that but we we just do a little bit of
everything and I have I help as I can
it's a great team is it strange to be
working on all these aspects of chess
did you see yourself coming into the
chess world and being this immersed in
this great game so if you had told me
when I was in Museum Studies school I
probably wouldn't
I don't think this museum existed when I
was in school so I wouldn't have known
but it's a really fun place to be well
the museum existed but not here in st.
Louis I think in between when I was in
school I think Miami had closed and then
st. Louis had not yet open so it was
like and it's in between phase but I
mean it's I think st. Louis is such a
wonderful home for it because like with
this tournament you can see we're making
history here you know as we catalog it
over across the street we have the new
tournament now what kind of new exhibits
can we expect to see may be coming up
shortly so the next show that will have
is exploring 80 years of the US Chess
Federation so we'll have
everything from some artifacts related
to the predecessor organizations
including probably the only chess trophy
that has antlers for handles which is
from the Western chess Association is
from the early 1900s all the way to
today so you know the tournaments that
we have here in st. Louis
the US Championships women's
Championships girls junior to Junior
Championships so there's a little bit of
something for everyone and theirs will
have contributions from people who've
been involved with chess live things
like that so that should be a lot of fun
I will be back at the u.s. championship
I'm gonna be sure to go to that one
you also do programming with kids and
adults tell us about that yes so some of
our most popular programming are our
monthly music series and those regularly
sell out and that's everything from
Bosnian music to like classical music a
little bit of something for everyone we
also do artistic kind of workshops so
sometimes they're inspired by our shows
so for example one of our other staff
members Nick Schleicher did a watercolor
workshop inspired by the colors and the
Peter Mannion show we also have toddler
Tuesday's so you can bring your little
ones out and they can look they won't
learn how to play chess but they'll
start to learn kind of some of the
skills that go into it so he's one of
our favorite sounds such great stuff
going on for everyone I've been there
many times thanks for all the work you
do we don't get to see folks like
yourselves often oh well thank you for
everything you do for us we wouldn't be
around if it weren't for these three
more question for you if somebody's
watching this and they have some kind of
amazing chess artifact or like anything
historic oh yeah a letter that they
don't know what to do with who should
they contact about potentially that's a
really amazing question so we patrons
can reach out to us not only if they
want to donate to us but even if they
want to learn a little bit more about it
and so I can answer questions about kind
of the history of things or we can
connect people with that
or you can reach out to our registrar
Nicole tessmer and her email address is
on our website world chess Hof dot org
donate donate something you own could be
in the world chess Hall of Fame
on display pretty much forever yeah and
I mean you'll be among some of the
biggest names in chess Yaser he's
donated a lot to our collection in the
past and then we have things you know
connected with other Hall of Famers
Jacquelyn Piatigorsky Arthur biscaia
Isaac Ashton
those are some of hands berliner those
are some of our bigger donations that
we've received in the past few years but
we really depend on kind of the everyday
person to help support our collection
too thanks very much for your work great
stuff in game thank you